aaron thank you for being with me today
thanks harris
let's start there let's start with the
law and order issue
and what's happening in philadelphia yet
another
city democrat-led city in america
because those are just the facts
that has devolved into nights of
violence
yeah it's really it's heartbreaking to
see because the first amendment of the
constitution
certainly protects people's right to
peaceably assemble
but that is not rioting and looting
president trump
is very clearly the president of safety
and security
of law and order and uh he has offered
assistance to any city that has ever
seen unrest like we are seeing
it's really heartbreaking to see because
if you remember back in august when
kenosha which is really a city very
close to my heart personally was burning
joe biden wasn't condemning that and he
went there to make a political statement
democrats did not talk about the
violence or the rioting or looting at
all
in the democrat convention because they
know that they can't they know that
those are people who are more likely to
vote for them than they are for
president trump
listen this is a president who believes
in law and order not only in word but in
action while democrats
stopped legislation in the senate tim
scott's bill
for better policing and better
communities president trump signed an
executive order to do
just that and he stands proudly with the
men and women of law enforcement
all right president uh trump as we move
to
the next thing here also uh being asked
a lot about if you will coronavirus and
and and we're seeing it
it's it's tough because in places you
mentioned kenosha and i used to live
next door in minnesota
the numbers of hospitalizations and
running out of beds
in wisconsin is really tough right now
let's talk about the president's closing
message on coronavirus and
and i know in the stump it can be
different but he's almost taunting it
saying covered covered covey covered
covet what is his closing message
well the message is clear the president
has fought to protect
millions of american lives and we know
joe biden would have been
leap years behind where the president is
when it comes to addressing the virus
i know it's hard for democrats to
remember but when the president was
making the state of the union address
he mentioned coronavirus and the next
day officials were
at the hill briefing officials on it i
know nancy pelosi pulled her political
stun
but it happened then and the president
has surged resources
ppe ventilators the white house is
tracking
what's going on in hospitals to make
sure if additional resources are
available
that they are sent ventilators and
therapeutics the president has stood up
the largest public-private partnership
and joe biden has said that the things
that the president has done were wrong
although his uh his plan for the
coronavirus seems eerily similar to the
president
just steps behind which we know would
cost
american lives and the only thing joe
biden would do differently
was not stop incoming flights from china
and we know
that saved lives president trump fights
for the american people
he is fighting against the coronavirus
and joe biden is an unmitigated disaster
who would have put us in a much worse
position versus the invisible enemy
why does the president from the the
lectern then when he speaks
almost make fun of the word kovid with
the crowds i mean
it it is something that stands out
well there's so much success in the
trump administration so many things
that should be talked about as well as
his exceptional response to the
coronavirus
just look at the last less than a week
in the president's uh
life thursday he had an exceptional
performance versus joe biden at the
debate
the next day another middle east peace
deal one of three
this president has been able to deliver
to make the world a safer place
and then on monday what did we see
justice amy
coney barrett where national networks
were not
carrying and covering her being sworn in
as a
mom a conservative and a
constitutionalist
to the supreme court of the united
states there are so many things going on
in this country
we should be talking about all of them
i want to get to women voters but let's
hear first on on just
from joe biden about the president's
pandemic response because i'll get your
reaction we'll move on to the next topic
he takes a lot of big pronouncements he
makes a lot of big pronouncements
but they don't hold up he gets his photo
op and
he gets out he leaves everyone else to
suffer the consequence of his failure to
make a responsible plan
it seems like he just doesn't care much
about it and the longer he's in charge
the more
reckless he gets it's enough
it's time to change
well 47 years of joe biden's failure is
not a change anybody in this country
should want we know what joe biden's
response looks like
to a pandemic and it's abysmal president
trump has stood
up against the chinese coronavirus to
make sure the american people
can safely live in this country to make
sure we have ppe and ventilators
and we will have a vaccine in record
time
and be able to get it to the american
people for free
because of president trump joe biden
likes to try and take
cheap cheap shots from the cheap seats
but we know president trump has fought
for the american people on this
and we know that joe biden doesn't
believe in that he doesn't believe in
the steps that need to be done to save
lives